ben affleck plays Matt Damon and Good
Will Hunting and Bourne Identity inside
of this movie called the accountant
where he's also autistic the accountant
all right let's start off with some
positives for positives for sure the
acting is really good sometimes I'd even
go as far as to say it's great if I were
to say watch this film it would
primarily be for Ben Affleck's
performance I don't know too many films
based on autistic characters but he's
definitely right up there with Rain Man
the first 30 to 40 minutes of this film
really takes his time to set up Ben
Affleck's character he does a great job
he's an accountant diagnosed with autism
and we get a decent amount of flashbacks
that really allow us to see how he's
been able to lead the life he currently
has I think Ben F we handled the role
really well he brought in a rather
subtle performance yet the entire time
you could feel like each moment of the
characters history on-screen you can
always see Ben Affleck is always
thinking is always aware it's always
processing even when this character is
just like having a normal interaction
you handle the autistic qualities pretty
well because this role is also an action
role and I can imagine an actor really
trying to showcase the autistic side but
his character is strongly about
concealing his identity keeping secrets
so he does his best to hide these traits
so I love how he internalized everything
emotionally but proceeded with the role
intellectually I feel like I said that
pretty well there was no noise going on
outside before I started filming this
video
no noise there's also some pretty damn
good supporting performances in here
Jeffrey Tambor he really stood out to me
without revealing too much he's one of
the mentors that Ben applix character
has and he's not in a lot of the movie
but the few scenes he has he adds a lot
of life to the role Anna Kendrick also
adds a nice personality touch to the
film and although her character isn't
the most interesting it's only because
her character is supposed to be the more
normal regular kind of person the scenes
she hasn't been applica really well
acted even though there are times where
I didn't really buy the writing or the
direction of where the film was taking
her character with Ben Affleck I felt
that she still maintained solid
chemistry with him and did her best to
justify certain things and of course Jon
Bernthal it's cool seeing him in here
everything I can recall seeing Jon
Bernthal in he's usually putting some
type of accent or voice on who's cool
hearing his normal speaking voice kind
of just sounds
bro and then this performance he also
got a chance to really showcase his
charismatic size from standout roles he
had in like the walking dead or in as
The Punisher on Netflix I'm used to
seeing him be you know like extremely
serious so it was nice seen a much more
charming Jon Bernthal but that's not to
say he doesn't have a scene or two that
showcases he's still a great dramatic
actor and I really enjoyed the first 30
to 40 minutes of this film honestly
about 20 minutes in I asked myself like
why is everyone hating on this is this
pretty good [ __ ] and then after his
scene on a farm it's starting that he
became pretty aware why it what the
problems are I don't want to give away
spoilers so here's what I'll say first
30 to 40 minutes there's actually a lot
of originality in there it does a really
good job of setting up its characters
not just Ben Affleck with the supporting
roles and you really aren't intrigued by
the accountant you see this man was born
autistic had a very troubling childhood
then he grew up and then he likes to go
gun shooting and he likes to uncooked
books for criminals but it also takes
time for character study seeing the way
he lives his life outside of accounting
was actually one of the more interesting
parts of the film beyond him being a
perfectionist of things there's a couple
of really well acted in well Shaw
moments where he's like meditating in
loud music and flashing lights that's
what I like to do before I call a Tyrone
Magnus on the phone and the set up of
the plot that's pitched in the trailer
how he gets involved in an accounting
case and then some [ __ ] starts to go
wrong it was cool at first and also a
lot for a really great like uplifting
scene between him and Anna Kendrick when
things start to go wrong it starts to do
some cool stuff in the way how it's
affecting Ben Affleck this man who must
be in control is just losing it that
lasts for like five minutes and there's
this like really cool action scene at a
farm it was a really really cool action
scene but then after that I just took a
big left turn like into cliche miss
mystery thriller film which to be blunt
the mystery is not all that thrilling so
to call this a thriller just like it's
not the real me granted the film still
periodically offers up some pretty cool
action sequences and there's other
scenes too that are pretty good so the
film doesn't entirely lose it
it did something weird where it kept
going from just cliche predictable just
downright expositional into oh that's
actually a cool thing just like it goes
back and forth three those two John
let's go you here's okay in the role
it's not like I felt like John Lithgow
did a bad job or even if the role really
required a lot of depth I just felt like
that was a missed opportunity you got a
great actor in a role that could have
easily been more enhanced to give you a
great supporting role and then the most
annoying part of the film is that
there's like plot twists and turns and
reveals and I think one of them was kind
of cool that involved Commissioner
Gordon but all the other ones like the
one that involves Punisher there's one
main plot turn involving Jon Bernthal
that comes in very late into the film
I'm not gonna give it away but the
second I saw Jon Bernthal I was like oh
he's that character he's this person I I
know it already and then as the film
kept going I was like wait a minute are
they trainers like set this up as a
twist or a reveal cuz I thought they
were just gonna establish this thing
like five minutes after we just met Jon
Bernthal and then they just hold on to
it and then when they finally revealed
it they tried making it like it's this
huge insane thing and then I couldn't
help but feel that you would have had a
much more interesting film if you put
that reveal like midway through the film
and then you allow that reveal to affect
the plot a little bit it just would have
made for a much more intriguing more
personal plot driven movie instead of
just an oh my gosh moment at the end
when it's not really oh my gosh the film
that some pretty good flashbacks but
there's also just way too much
flashbacks and some flashbacks oh I'm
just like we didn't you see that and it
doesn't make sense like even before the
cool farm sequence we get this flashback
that's like out of some bad kung fu film
when his characters like 12 or something
I just didn't think it was necessary to
show them do you really need to show is
that you could have just put it in a
sentence of like whatever it just seemed
like some flashbacks were someone
necessary that it would have been better
to allude to certain things or let the
audience kind of like come up with
something on their own here in a
character motive of Ben Affleck's
character instead of just showing us
some flashback that feels a little out
of place and I thought JK Simmons did a
good job JK Simmons is always good he
could have like one line in the film he
still rocks and I appreciated that they
went out of their way
to add more depth to this character then
normally would have just been a cliche
character at the same time though I felt
like they could have spread out his
story more throughout the film but
instead they give us this one scenery
monologues for like ten straight minutes
it was just a lot of flashbacks over it
and it kind of comes in like at some
random point in the film so it doesn't
even feel like like this was the right
timing for this epic explanation I feel
like an amateur writing maneuver that's
not to say that I'm like a great writer
or anything I mean I am I'm the best
writer right now I can't think of anyone
better than me Sorkin go [ __ ] yourself I
clearly have the IMDB credits to prove
that hello noise from the other side it
was a bummer to see the hell this great
stuff involving JK Simmons his character
that that all got I don't wanna say
shoehorned but sort of like overstuffed
all in one scene that didn't quite seem
to fully justify like him giving this
huge explanation the basic problem with
everything is that after that great
action sequence at the farm the film
becomes so heavily about just moving the
plot forward moving the reveals and
turns from this so-called mystery
forward and there's no real emotional
stakes like yes Ben Affleck he kicks ass
in this role but I never ever once felt
like he was in any sort of real danger
he didn't seem like he was in danger of
dying it seemed like it was in danger of
even losing it looked like it was gonna
do this thing where this man gets put in
a dangerous situation he's gonna start
making non rational decisions very
emotional based decisions that could
lead to some serious consequences which
would have been a cool film but instead
it's just Ben Affleck handling business
man so what makes for an enjoyable film
I can't help but feel that there's a
great film in here this is from Warner
Brothers so they probably cut it
horribly afterwards
so yeah this film could have been
something of a great masterpiece but
instead it's another missed opportunity
where the best thing about it is Ben
Affleck q Batman V Superman poster so
yeah well my new rating system I would
give it
it's okay alright guys subscribe to the
real rejects become a rejected a YouTube
things stay like that and you can follow
me on Instagram I actually use that so
there's one social media you actually
want to follow me on you go there and
here in YouTube and sayonara amigo